in unsere inspiration auch tommy geht es
dieses mal um body possibility als model
kate wesley mischt instagram schon seit
einer weile mit einzigartigen spiegels
11 es auf das besondere an ihren fotos
und ermutigende botschaften die sie mit
lippenstift auf den spiegel schreibt
dabei spricht sie themen wie cellulite
psychische gesundheit dehnungsstreifen
und abnehmen an in ihren post geht es
darum den eigenen körper zu akzeptieren
so wie er ist wie sie zu diesem mindset
gekommen ist verriet sie ihrer community
unter diesem vorher nachher bild sie
erzählt ihre persönliche geschichte und
von ihrem kampf mit einer essstörung
sie schreibt sie habe nun eine normale
beziehung zu ihrem körper und zum essen
und die ist ein gewaltiger fortschritt
für sie
diese offenheit und ihre inspirierende
einstellungen finden wir top
[Musik]